folks okay I got to do
this
okay so the CHS are still
stuck and we're just going to have to do
a little bit of
up to provide a little bit of context
here
um Captain in
guy has submitted a pretty cool
environment it is a physics based Arena
shooter hey how's it going man um so
what we're going to be doing right now
is trying to help him debug it
it's this is like pretty typical
situation in reinforcement learning you
have an environment it's not as fast as
you want it to be and it's not training
so we caught one major bug already which
was actually a puffer Li bug for
once um and then we're going to
see what else we can figure out from
here
so let me
think now the one thing that's a little
bit annoying here is that the structure
of this
code is um it's not exactly as simple as
I would like it to
be so typically we just put all the code
in one. h file there are a lot of them
and I don't fully know the structure of
it um
believe
P
Wards shot hit
reward some rewards hey Captain overview
of the
structure sure I'm H I'm happy to jump
in uh I can even get you on voice if you
are wanting to do that
here uh you I thought you were out for
an
errand yeah so win
reward kill reward and then shot hit
reward
Aaron was delegated very good let me see
if I can figure out how to get you on
the stream that would be a fun thing to
do if you're comfortable doing that I
don't know I just stream everything by
default because it's
easy
um let me see if I turn
this uh and I get in
Discord that probably
works test
input it doesn't like it when you use
the same mic for two things apparently
but that's fine I have this nice
headset I have this nice headset for
Voice
output try
this yeah that should work
uh
here I'm trying to think what it would
be
initially things that could be wrong hey
Captain hey all right I'll go ahead and
perfect I can hear you and I think
stream can as
well people can let me know if you're
heing double or whatever I see bets on
the
stream um
so I thought there wasn't really any
stream is delayed by a bit well you
don't need this you don't need the
stream on if uh you're hearing voice
with me
right just I guess yeah stre you're
gonna be hearing
double oh I muted it just I was just
thinking so I could see what you know
she see your oh it's going to be a few
seconds delayed it's probably the
quickest on which I can also probably
can I double this I think this machine's
probably good enough to double
uh hold
on if this doesn't work and I have to
reboot my machine you'll know why but I
will try to screen share this as
well
actually yeah I don't even need this
virtual cam cool so now I have this
framing um
so you said that it typically learns to
not fire any bullets if you have bad
hyper
parameters that doesn't really make much
sense to me so on the sweep I've been
running with your fix like the actions
fix it's that's not the case anymore at
least from what I've been seeing um let
me send do you have some good parameters
for me uh I don't say good parameters
but it I mean it looks a little better
um I'm gonna have to do some accounting
on all these boxes lately to see if I
can spot you a
box because you're doing some good work
here it's mostly I just need that I need
that guy to finish solving Pokemon so we
can get four of them
back yeah that'd be nice proba won't be
for a
bit that's all right that's a really
cool
project all right I sent it in uh the
general chat Channel I can send it
somewhere else if that's easier mhm
so sorry the voice yeah okay so let's
see what we have
here and uh you know this is generally
how I like doing stuff because like you
know I have you build this environment
and then you get to see how I like how I
look at stuff and how I generally debug
stuff in RL so this looks a lot
healthier than before so before it was
really really sparse we had like a
couple things that seemed like they were
working I don't even know how that's
possible by the way that you were
getting any to work with the actions
being that messed up um but this looks I
mean possibly healthier I don't know how
this compares to
random so we'll see on that let's see
entropy it's the best one we've got
o09 yeah that's fine low entropy but
fine lambda's fine gamma is a bit low
how many steps per second does this
environment take and by that I mean um
like if you were to play one second of
the game right like in real time how
many time like how many observations is
that oh um so I do a frames skip before
so I guess like 20 or 15 yeah okay yeah
so a uh a gamma that's at 0.85 is kind
of insane yeah I know that doesn't
pretty low because that just means like
okay you get like four or five step look
ahead so this thing was about a
effective Horizon of about a quarter of
a second which really doesn't make any
sense for your environment right if this
were like Connect Four this would make
total
sense you
see no I agree I mean it's supposed to
be like 95 and above but that's still
ridiculous because again you know 95 is
20 so it's still like less than that's
like a little over a
second
right so here what do we have here we've
got these charts don't tell us much yeah
those aren't really important I don't
know what this best OBS
is
oh if you change like the user at the
top like the NW career parameter to like
Captain space hook it should show it to
be cleaner because I've like customized
the charge and stuff how you do that so
at the very top like in the URL um I
don't know how else to do it so where it
says huh yeah if you just remove the NW
user like just change J Suarez no the
very end yeah I know I'm get the very
end of the okay yeah just change it with
Captain space hook
and yeah we'll see if that
works perfect yeah that's that's better
okay so distance traveled goes
up yeah so I made an absolute differ
distance because distance traveled is
just if it's basically shaking back and
forth but net distance is like yeah kind
not going much you can see how they're a
lot different well that's just going to
happen because look at the
length so what's the Criterion here for
length um just amount of steps and
that's like raw steps like in like not
so
umer I guess yeah but um I ealed this
and it still is kind of
weird and there's no death penalty from
what I saw there's no death penalty but
there is a reward for winning
basically yeah I can add back the death
penalty I just wasn't sure if it was
like G to make agents too scared or
[Music]
something and yeah I think I saw you
looking at rewards earlier the rewards
right now are really simple I don't know
how good they are but um because this
game you know you're trying to push your
opponent into walls and I was trying to
figure out a reward such that you're not
like basically signaling like okay if
you hit him with like say sniper rifle
that you're moving them a lot but that's
one shot so you should be rewarded more
but you should also like not be rewarded
like a ton if you hit them a bunch of
times with like a weak weapon like
machine gun you know I think what's
going to happen is you're going to use
these initially to get it going and then
eventually once we figure out what's
wrong you're not even going to need
those rewards um right we don't want to
reward for just shooting yeah yeah so
well it's it's not it's rewarding for
hitting the opponent but yeah ideally
would they could like learn to just like
shoot keep shooting at each other and
like pushing each other back a little
bit and like they can do weird stuff I
think like when win loss is good and
then stuff that's like very very clearly
not gameable there in is good like maybe
like getting you get like a reward for
like getting the pickups or
whatever um we'll see about that but in
any event um how do I play this thing
like how do I just make the C
build okay so make sure you switch to
master and then just pull so I like merg
everything into master and fixed like a
few things that I did already set up all
this like compiler
Shenanigans yeah yeah so I I fixed that
you shouldn't need to worry about
that okay what do you change this was
just the old messing with just fre to be
fair we haven't tested continuous super
extensively I can ask K if he did
anything with that yeah I can try um
multi- discreet actions and see if that
helps at
all okay did you change the default
Branch back to
master yeah um was funny so
yeah funny as hell um yeah I edit I
copied clean puffer RL or whatever back
when I like started um porting Super
Mario Land environment to PU puffer
which is a while ago and I just didn't
update it so yeah um that's funny so
make um debug demo debug hyphen
demo and then
yeah oh that's right I did not actually
I think what are your thoughts on
Thousand line version of box 2D at some
point that's just one file that we don't
have to [ __ ] deal with this mess
yes please I mean that'd be nice but it
probably be there's got to be some
automated way to hopefully take
something like boxi and and create like
a single header file because if we can
do that in automated fashion think we
could just make it smaller like there's
a bunch of stuff in that Library we
don't
need I mean sure but then that's going
to that's going to make it hard to keep
up like make it uh keep up to date with
upstream and we don't want to like
diverge too far up I mean like
box yeah let's see we don't care if it's
stable is stable that's a super project
boxd has been stable
forever I mean yeah but they they just
came out with a near major version like
a couple months ago and changed a lot
all right they actually moved from C++
to C like in August I think that's the
only reason we're using it um yeah is
okay so now how do I run this
thing um so you can let me
yeah let me push really quick because I
actually just um like B you can just run
it right now so uh it's in debug demo
just demo so just run thebug demo
demo so again I you can try doing it
mouse and keyboard but it's G to kind of
suck well first of all the keys are
backwards oh no the keys are not
backwards that just indicator weird yeah
it's so that's from the original game it
makes sense to me I can maybe change if
everyone disagrees but it's like it's
acting really slow isn't it so yeah
that's the point so shoot start shooting
it's not slow it's too fast well the
there we go the W pick up a weapon and
then it'll start getting a lot faster so
the thing is your movement is
intentionally slow because your movement
is
like most of your movement comes from
recoil so you shoot something with that
oh like yeah yeah
hi gab H what's
up hey you are currently on stream for
reference just letting people know
welcome as well oh yeah yeah you're
working you're the guy working on uh
Pac-Man right yeah yeah cool welcome
we're currently trying to debug
this en of captains this is so cool by
the way this this uh
CLI what's this to
oh that's cool uh this CLI doesn't do
this game Justice at all we should make
something like way uh not CLI this
client doesn't do the game Justice at
all we should do something like way
cooler for you what uh what is the game
it uh it's I'm streaming it here it's
the physics it's like this physic
shooter oh nice yeah it's based off of
retrograde Arena it's not a super
popular game but it's freeo playay in
Steam and switch it's pretty fun there
we go nice you just won good job Joseph
yeah I see um so can we check rewards
somehow here if they're uh print rewards
you should be logging
them uh oh I see it is logging them does
it log all of them yeah every time a
nonzero W happens you it shows
it picked up weapon so that's not a
reward it'll say like reward that's just
like sanity checking me making sure I
get the logging stats correctly which
they are but as far as I know at
least whoa yeah so the thing about this
game is you have to like ideally if
you're shooting say up you wouldn't be
also
one yeah one so I issue one right now if
you just win
basically and then you hit them so you
did got like a tiny award for just like
moving them a little bit again I'm open
to ideas if that if that isn't great is
it okay there
reward I just got it three times though
yeah yeah so it's constant is it a
constant the frame skip that's just a
logging thing it didn't actually issue
it three times it's just a Bas like
artifact of how I log in frame skip I I
actually debugged that for a while and
I'm like why am I issuing this mul I'm
like nope I'm actually not it's just how
I'm logging it
so
yeah I should maybe like add the frame
skip or something to the log and then
that make it more clear
but so yeah if you want to get round
faster just shoot behind
you yeah rip that's fun this is where
mouse and keyboard comes or this is
where controller comes in handy because
you can start zooming around with a
shotgun or whatever I think it's just
skill issue
honestly I like games but I'm very bad
at
them that reward of
one yeah it's pretty
high no that's fine is it always going
to because didn't didn't he just
lose so whatever player wins gets the
reward so if he dies I think I might I
think I did win it just was really fast
how do we see who get who's getting the
reward it just say reward
zero well the zero is the index of the
agent so I lost whoa whoa whoa oh reward
I see reward one yeah but that's the
opponent okay yeah you got the reward
your rewards look good have you check
them in
Python um I mean from the wandy B logs
they look like
sane I haven't like verified that I'm
getting the same rewards over there if
that's what you
mean I've checked them and they get to
python this is pretty sweet thanks man
yeah this is I need to add some more
weapons this is like we need to throw at
least some cool shaders on this if not
like a cool 3D client
because you basically have like you have
a full game implemented you just have
like really barebones Graphics if you
think about it right
yeah yeah we we talked about it he he's
like I care that works yeah let work
first right yeah so what what happens
when you try to train it uh it just
doesn't also doesn't
work oh that's so that's one thing I'm
not sure okay so
currently I think need to do the
inputting inside so right now I do the
uh controller inputs in the C file but I
think I need to do them okay totally but
um due to the way like frame skipping
works I'm like only taking inputs in
like once every four frames which can
make it annoying oh maybe that's why
Everything feels slow yeah if you so if
you go edit um M settings H and change
frame skip to one then playing it all
night cuz it's actually kind of fun um
let me see I want to figure out if we
can get this training for you now yeah
so I'm trying to think what the
easiest thing to start on this is I'm
actually I'm like very suspicious of
those parameters because they really
don't make any
sense are you looking at the some of the
runs from new sweep well yeah this one
here like okay shops fire goes up but
shops hit
doesn't I know well
um yeah I can either stream or send you
some policies for you to like uh see
they they I don't know they still kind
of be some of the policies seem to be
kind of shooting in one location always
like before some of them just seem to be
kind of doing random stuff so but yeah
if you look at the
curves yeah um I'm not really sure why
okay you set mini batch good and then
9990 so like like you said an
coefficient Lambda Gamma and learning
rate are being swapped over everything
else is
currently does it know which bot it
is uh it
should
um think
[Music]
um I guess maybe not I guess based on
the uh like observation like the Drone
observation let me
see let's actually take a look let's see
what you're
doing
yeah oops no
trap want be
here yeah those are just various
properties you can take a look in M uh
her like source and is this your is this
your drone
properties yes and not the Enemy No it's
it's just yours I I
asked um yeah it's in the uh like the
map
observation okay that's just a one hot
of like what weapon you
have
zero
Z
who uh let's see what this is
what is this supposed to be is that this
diagonal sus
yeah I wonder if you did the uh the
Xander uh the Xander bug what's
that a let's see if you have the Xander
bug um there thre is making a big Z on
there is that theander that's what hold
on on
see uh
Max sell
permute yeah I should have a p mute
download see so that looks correct but
it depends on how you l this thing out
in
memory compute
OBS so we go over
agents M and then what's this first you
go over cells so cells is basically like
all the walls and weapon
pickups yeah oh sorry yeah yeah the
first Loop is Asian are correct my bad
and then this is
size is this filling in this first layer
right
here uh what do you mean first layer so
this Loop here yes is this that's
filling in walls is it filling in I see
how I've zero colon colon zero MH is
this what this is doing
uh it should be yeah basically it fills
out like most of it and then I think
this is wrong yeah it might be I think
this is wrong
then
um I think you have the Xander bug but
you have it a reverse Xander buug I
think what was a Xander
buug uh I will show
you let me see if this is it's
possible it's definitely possible have a
b or bug in here because I did this
pretty quick yesterday and didn't ver
have time to verify too much
zero
and what is the
uh
striping what is
three
uh so this is before I one hot it yeah
what is three though
um I guess it
depends cuz wait this is the first
channel right yeah that's a death wall
okay so should or wait that's a is it a
death should it not be like the outside
of the map is surrounded in this yeah it
should be so it should just be so if
this is correct it should be the threes
are on the outside of the like the
outside of the wall right like it should
just be surrounded by
threes yeah I think on that map yeah um
if we really want to check and make it
easier if you go into m.h so right now I
have it hardcoded just to be on one map
just I don't know to make training
easier I ideally like to randomize Maps
but if you go to m.h uh I think it's a
setup M search for that function yeah so
I guess you don't have line numbers but
see where says map index equal one if
you change that to zero that's just a
Bare Bones map um it's literally just
got walls surrounding and that's it that
should make it even easier to bug
wait if I change this to what
zero oh I see and then just
uh you have to remake the uh yeah python
stuff
again it's not just pip install dashy
what is it to like rebuild um you can
pip install Dash Tac e or pip install
period but it'll be way slower because
it builds in an isolated environment
rebuilds is it just make DJ or what is
it just make we'll do it because it's
the top Target make it faster you don't
need the D J because it uses ninja
okay and if UFC cash install it'll also
use
that
y
um file format not recogniz oh that's
because I actually fixed the compiler
bug so but that requires you like wipe
out your ccache so just make clean and
then do it again and then it should
work
right you're going to have to it's going
to be a tough sell on uh on this over
just having to freaking build
Dosh yeah I I get what you mean or I I
have no love for seake like I have a
love haate relationship with it but I
think for something like this like with
I don't know I could so basically but
the way that I've done stuff that's been
pretty effective is just like absolutely
having no respect for the complexity of
any of these environments and just
saying nope all the logic you're going
in a file you're going in here with like
a brain dead code and no build system
and that has ironically been the easiest
thing I know i' I've seen your build sh
though and it's like I don't know I'm
just not a fan of like hardcoding like
uh like the raou stuff or whatever like
I don't know that's testing though
that's just that's just for testing
it's just for the local SE bus yeah what
this is but um this is python Now isn't
it should be yeah that setup do just our
setup.py just does that yeah and the
setup the high was crazy like I don't
know this is definitely like opinion but
I would much rather have like a cake
rather than like the insanity that what
you're seeing is just complexity due to
it needing to handle everything in
puffer no I know a lot of up high is
like the other stuff puffer handles and
I get that but I wasn't a fan of like
the hardcoded like rayb like static
liary some other stuff so I'm like all
right I'm just gonna because this was
really easy to get working on Mac and
Linux with different compilers like
whatever like I don't really have to do
hardly anything it just works on Mac all
right
so well I will definitely consider it
more if it works for older compiler
versions the main thing is just screwing
with users with like extra tools that
don't work is like no
no I totally get that yeah this is like
to the point that like I you have you
noticed like I just rejected a preit PR
because it's like no I'm not do that
screw off right it's like don't come
into my house and rearrange my
furniture I mean I'm I'm Pro linting but
I see what you mean there because yeah
like having a having a PR that like
lints everything or p in the ass not
lints everything um formats everything
you know that guy that guy did
specifically give the feedback that you
literally gave like after as well Joseph
uh you know don't commit a pre
commit yeah why I just merged the guy's
small builds like his main fix but
anyways what what do you expect
um what yeah it it a good contribution
but yeah it's not best practice
say
right I just I want there to be fewer
practices and fewer things for people
like this [ __ ] doesn't have to be that
hard well hey the one really nice thing
about my setup is the scon file is way
simpler because you don't have to like
the autox I'm open to actually if it
consistently works and doesn't have
setup pain in the ass I'm actually open
to that um than anything it's yeah it
ain't perfect because if you notice like
I have a couple of defines where
basically it would fail to parse stuff
but luckily the stuff it failed to parse
like didn't it didn't need to parse so I
just defined around it and I was like yo
if you're Auto PX I do not like [ __ ]
defines I would love to figure out how
to do it without that but we'll figure
that out later anyways let me make sure
we get this working for you first right
now before you have to head out
um so OBS is it map
OBS because I get distracted very easily
especially when I am exhausted
okay so this is not correct right like
the whole outside of this thing should
be threes I'm starting to I see some
like diagonal striping as well yeah
which means there's probably like an
order screw up right yeah this is
definitely our problem at least one of
many hopefully not many but could be
this this would be a pretty good
candidate this was Xander's main
bug as well so
uh trick number one check your
observations in Python in your forward
pass right before they go into the
network yeah that makes sense I said
that yeah to
be from
where yes but also recommended
originally by car
pathy oh who who's that
L bet I know you know
that great guy did a bunch of awesome
work at Stanford back in the day was
Chief scientist at Tesla did some stuff
at open AI for a while um and now is
doing whatever he's also responsible for
uh a good chunk of the actually
highquality educational material out
there in deep
learning that's cool uh I I interned
under one of his colleagues in the same
lab in fa's lab in high school so I got
to chat with him a bit back then
yeah I've been meaning to do some more
troubleshooting but have been a little
strapped for time cuz I with family for
a bit all right see this is not a cluck
in job it's oh I know I'm just I'm just
saying like bet saying like oh I've
suggested that and yeah like you gave me
some good advice I just haven't had time
to take advantage of it that's
all
yeah what was that Discord noise do
someone join or leave hi thank you
welcome welcome to the
stream oh yeah welcome FYI if you're
talking on here you will be on stream
hello to the YouTube and twitch
folks we are currently debugging a
really cool
environment
um okay so we have this now so we do
z0 so this gives us what where we were
before
and then if we do
21215 do
permute and this is going to be 0 31
now maybe we should verify that there
actually looks like this isn't the right
dimensions is what this looks like like
um yeah I'm thinking we should check the
C because I don't even know if the C is
correct let me say
so hang on but these shouldn't be
adjacent either way
right no I mean it yeah it's should look
it shifted is it is it possible this is
shifted CU if you shift this over by two
then you get a three here and the next
three goes to
here is it possible that these
dimensions are incorrect like are the C
Dimensions mismatch somehow
um hold on uh so the 21 by 21 is the max
Map size there are some maps that are 20
by 20 20 by 20 pause
this yeah that might be
it um yeah I think that's it then
because actually yeah the um the map
that was originally on before was a 20
by 20 map okay how do I get a 21 by 21
uh let me go the map
so
um all right in map. I Define all the
maps if you
set
um okay yeah set um the thing you
changed before yeah set that to two you
should have a 21 by 21
map and then like yeah yeah do the mate
command again
so you could I want this fine though
hold on H the multiprocessing
messages yeah so like I said you could
pip install but you do the entire build
every time which takes forever so well I
do the majority of my environment
testing in C and then just stuff like
this is in Python so yeah and by testing
I don't mean unit tests yeah yeah I know
you mean I mean screwing with it until
looks
right I'm actually one of the things I'm
looking forward to is AI getting good
enough to write unit tests and then
throw them
away throw them away yeah so you're not
maintaining shitty AI unit tests it's
just finding
bugs persisting unit test can be helpful
though for code that's yeah I hate
maintaining
them so AI should be able to maintain
the unit tests or just rewrite them yeah
just basically just a sophisticated
fuzzer no I completely
agree that looks better what's a two
yeah that that looks accurate um it's
got this big thing in the center yeah
that looks about
right so if that's so the good news is
you did not have the Xander Buton
bu I know it's was kind of mean to call
it to Zander bug it's like a very common
bug I've screwed that up so many damn
times I was gonna say I don't I don't
look or feel any worse about him I I
make all kinds of bugs yeah dude if you
knew the stupid [ __ ] that I've done over
the years holy hell I mean every
programmer has if you program long
enough oh man I think the best one is
there is a we're going to train this um
there is legitim l in some old Stanford
research repo from when I was
16 uh there is a parser for uh word net
which is like this dag
for and like anemology word anemology or
whatever um but I didn't know what a dag
was so it's like 14 deep nested for
loops and
recursive that's got to be the worst
thing I've ever written
um so wait did you actually change
anything what did you actually end up
changing anything I just changed it to a
map that actually is correct for these
observations oh okay so if I'm okay so I
I'm doing um 21 by 21 so does that mean
I can't you like train on 20 x 20 maps
without doing some I don't know shifting
around of the observations have to fix
your OBS buffers
all okay your OBS buffer wrong size by
the way this would be fixed if you did
it
entric if I did what if you did it
entric so if you did it a fixed crop
window around the agent and then that
would also allow you to do that would
give you basically the same
benefits um my camera's lagging because
of uh the GPU running on this um it
would give you the same benefits but
then at the same time uh you would
actually be able to scale it so you
could do like a smaller Vision version
that trains faster or you could do the
full 21 by 21 for instance which lets
you see which lets you see halfway
across the map if you're in the center
like you do
whatever yeah I could try that I I'm not
totally posted to that but I would
really like to have a I don't know if
it's impossible then like I mean it is
what it is but it'd be nice to have
agents see the whole map because humans
can um but like in the normal game but I
mean that certainly doesn't sound
impossible it's not it's just slightly
slower and it's like annoying because
your OB size changes based on what map
you're playing which is just a pain for
neural
generally I mean maybe you could train
it for the maximum Map size and then uh
if the map is smaller than that um
offset it by some like fixed amount for
that
episode you could try that I think you'd
probably want to center it on the you'd
probably just want to like Center it or
actually you might not have to Center
you might actually well you could
probably have variable obiz buffer but
not in like that you wouldn't be able to
mix the maps in one run so yeah you'd
have to pad or
something yeah padding really pick a
stick to it otherwise make a make a good
generalist
agent yeah it's like there're just
battles that you fight and battles that
you don't and honestly like the majority
of environments people are usually
pretty happy about egocentric precisely
because it's easier to scale like if you
did it egocentric then you could make
like a 500x 500 map and it would just
work yeah
yeah that's why people generally get
excited about stuff uh what where's my
my sweep run
thing 5 hours ago I I typed track here
is this not
oh so um because it's my project I
defaulted like the way DB uh stuff to be
like me so you might have actually uplo
it to mine I and I forgot since I pulled
I guess the quickest fix for now to get
this to work on 20 x 20 Maps is yeah
probably just apply some pading to like
the start so that's it's kind of
centered in that space think a possible
I don't know maybe just could you only
consider one Map size that may be the
simplest way to get started could yeah I
was just um I was just porting maps from
the original game and then
from what I can tell pretty much mostly
20 or 20 by 20 or 21 by 21 so I could
just relegate it to like either one for
now but
um yeah I think if I'm doing a 20 by 20
I could just basically um add an extra
zero at the end of each row does not
seem to have fixed
everything okay actually this may not be
the best map because this map defaults
to the sniper rifle um so then you have
to charge it oh yeah be able Lear it's
not like it's not as easy to learn
though yeah know holding down a button
is actually really pain in the ass thing
in
RL we can I mean just think about it's
on intuitive if you don't like I mean
it's kind of like with a human if it's
like yeah instead of holding down had to
tap these like four keys in a row that
we don't tell you right if you just make
it like some random shibolet then uh
people aren't going to do it
either yeah well if you want to it can
be yeah we can edit the map to make it
the default weapon like the standard
weapon if you want really
easily let's try that next because also
this is like lagging the hell out of
everything burning my GPU burning my CPU
heating up my
room h let's
see so if we want to if you do want to
change the weapon you have to go to map.
H killing this because it's lagging
everything it's actually like more laggy
than most stuff uh I don't know why
maybe it's the
multi-processing most of the Puffs you
know they literally work on One Core if
you want them to cuz they're that
fast thank you for the thank you for the
prizing yeah if uh for folks on YouTube
if you have not starred the puffer Li
repo please go ahead and do that it
really helps us out a lot and no we will
not be getting cheap viewers get out of
here stupid
bot all right where's default weapon
so go to keep going down a little bit
and you'll see the snipers map yeah and
change default weapon to stand or keep
going down a little
bit yeah um default weapon right there
change that to standard
weapon
yeah and then just rebuild you should be
good make a Das
J you can do make dhj but the dhj won't
change anything all make
um because yeah ninja uses all CPU cores
by default as far as I
know which is nice and it's a lot faster
than
make and it's actually required for S
kit build core whatever what you're GNA
have to explain to me at some point what
you're doing with pit build core it's
just a way way way simpler um method of
uh building a python module like a c
python module basically
it's python modable C
bindings you don't have to deal with
like setup. high at all it's like uh 10
lines if that in like your Pi project.
toml it's really nice if you UC see make
basically you have all the wri see make
and you just tell diit build core to
just like run it basically so it's nice
otherwise you have this giant like in my
opinion not super maintainable set up
that high I'm not really set up High
stuff if you can't tell but that's fine
I don't think I mean tython tooling just
sucks in general so yeah it does this is
very different hold
on which one is the new one
three doing
well certainly a lot more shots taken
shots hit shots fired
Bush interesting that reward reward is
about
flat yeah I mean it's the sum of both
agents it's a zero some game so I think
it makes sense but you have drone one
and Dr Drone zero
reward yeah should still go up to a
point because they're not getting for
getting hit so they should both hitting
each other
more but yes you're right that you do
end up with the annoying selfplay
problem at some
point
yeah what's the what's the selfplay
problem uh it's just that in general
it's really annoying to track progress
in selfplay environments because your
performance relative to the other agent
but the other agent is you so it's flat
so then you have to do ELO
which you can do but they're just a pain
to do and integrate
correctly and you don't
have you just don't get like nice clean
metrics that you can track as
easily yeah I my uh my only experience
with selfplay was super simple Tic Tac
Toe self play and there you have a
minmax that you can compare against so
there's a convenient metric but uh
that's what en is we just Implement some
scripted opponent
usually um and you don't have to do that
for forever but like even in Dota they
spent like a month and a half just
trying to make like a really good
scripted bot to play against and they
use that for a lot of their early work
so I did the same in the Moa I didn't do
it in nurl M Mo three amusingly enough I
think I just I've written too many nurl
mo scripted BS over the years and I was
sick of it but uh I got it working
anyways well I mean some point you want
to get perform
much better than any scripted bot could
could achieve and then you
know doesn't really yeah work as a
metric
anymore this thing doesn't save us some
nice checkpoints to watch that does it
it doesn't no it does now if you pull I
I changed it oh you did yeah where are
they cool uh they they follow the
standard puffer stuff so check points
whatever the Wy be like ID should be
all right we'll let this save us
uh uh one more checkpoint or
whatever that's oh look it's
crashed
crash Tak look at
this where oh it's going down
yeah no that's not that's not
crashed is
crashed uh no clip Frack issues oh but
now it goes back up that's
fine yeah it's wacky
man welcome to the reinforcement
learning experience this this is the
thing that we're going to be addressing
this year or this coming year it's going
to be a lot of science side stuff and
reinforcement learning how to make
everything consistent
stable all right if you think this is
complicated this is this is nothing to
Joseph St like all the all the heavy
lifting so that we don't have to just be
lost in a bunch of stuff that just
doesn't work I've done what I can to
start with but I'm we're gonna really be
able to make stuff a lot easier in 2025
and we will be uh contributors are more
than welcome to help with that as well
great way to get into the more science
side
stuff yeah I'm definitely interested in
that it sounds really interesting to me
I will definitely be pulling people from
uh from like environment contributors
who give a [ __ ] it does take you a while
to train people to be able to do some of
that
work so while we're waiting I'm curious
I know you mentioned before think yeah
goe oh I was going to kill it and grab
the checkpoints um okay yeah I want to
see ev yeah but what are you
saying oh I was just saying um the uh
distrib action distribution you were
saying like normal is very standard so
like for a lot of like muuk or whatever
like like continuous control tasks like
a lot of people just use like straight
normal action distribution and you know
for a bunch of different joints and it
works fine that's standard as far as I'm
aware
okay because I was wondering if I need
to do some like
fancy mul it's a criticism of the
current well the vast majority of
current
work um and here's the issue with RL
right like it's not like people are
completely unaware of this but the vast
majority of algorithmic results in RL
are just not defended by sufficient data
so anytime you see a fancy new method
you should assume it's wrong until
proven otherwise and being published in
a top paper and having a ton of
citations does not necessarily mean it's
correct either it's that
bad yeah I remember you saying that and
yeah I don't doubt
it is the solution to that just like
really rigorous statistics with we're
going to do I mean we're going to do it
this year the solution is that we can
train tens of trillions of steps of
experiments um per GPU per day so we
just have like we can just run so many
exhaustive experiments to stops being an
issue yeah I've definitely heard never
just use one seed for a result like well
but it's not that researchers are stupid
it's that people build the environments
to be too damn that was so
close these guys are not Geniuses wait
wa oh wait that's a that's a yellow
that's a yellow it doesn't lose yeah
yellow is bouncy just
lost yeah these guys are no Geniuses but
let's see if I do like 100
maybe I mean are they are they are they
supposed
to inherently
no that don't worry about that I'm not
oh
they actually hitting each other kind
oh they actually hitting each other kind of well they're they're not they're
of well they're they're not they're
spamming and avoiding wall is what it
looks like to me yeah although green
bounced off yellow but that could have
been
intentional I mean you'll certainly
score hits sometimes like that red just
goes right into the wall yeah R red lost
they both hit each other a little bit
there but I don't know how how
intentional it
was me that looks that looks better than
what I've evail better than before that
that being said all R that's not this is
not what we're going for we're going for
superum he this is uh well just for a
second there we had 10 viewers on the
stream that's fun welcome YouTube folks
takes a while to get the audience back
I've been like not consistent streaming
because I was doing neurl M mo3 and then
nurs and I got sick then I got the
Christmas Eve root canal and [ __ ]
but I will be back streaming a lot more
Dev
now you said you had a schedule before
what's your normal schedule
like if I'm actually being serious about
stuff it's get up at 6 run stream some
Dev go to the gym at noon uh come back
stream get dinner sleep
H are you on the Eastern time zone I'm
in Florida okay
okay yeah I don't know if you're still
in Florida or not in Florida until it
gets
hot trying to think what we should
do initially for this for you
what's randomized it's like start
position of the agents
randomized yeah start position of agents
and the uh contents and location of the
weapon pickups let's look for some stuff
so we got
length increasing length means
increasing survival
time yeah but then for some reason these
broken ones were surviving way longer oh
because they're not shooting each other
in the yeah
okay interesting
these ones are actually shooting each
other reward not going
up like yes it's self play but they
should be able to do
something weapons
pick the reward structure needs to be
visited so that it incentivizes playing
the game properly
Yeahs are optimal do they goe do they
perceive the bullets is that in the
observation it is but uh it's very
discretized or discretizer however say
that way you say that what is it ish
they perceive the bullets yeah kind of
yeah they have a general idea of where
they are I'd like to have make them have
like give them Absolute position
positions of bullets and stuff but as of
right now they they don't know exactly
where they are they's kind of no
map 04 10 16
20 it seems
right there should be 26 total it should
be walls first which they three but I
add one cuz like zero is no wall and
then it's um projectiles so there's five
+ one six and then
there's drone weapon type drones and
another six and
um leaky re yeah the Leaky re that's not
going to be the issue though
are the dimensions
of do you have a lazy linear in here or
something nothing's lazy oh you just
have a function that computes it
yeah I stole that from uh stable
baselines 3 I just found that to be
easier well to be fair if you're going
to do this there's it's called lazy
linear does that for you I I usually do
it manually though I usually do it
manually so that I know if I'm being
stupid or not yeah way to introduce bugs
but you can do that right hold on
where s
encoder what were you saying about the
comp 2D
Dimensions yeah are those those
correct uh stri
two KS three is a little or colel size
five is a
little so the reason again I don't know
if they're ideal or not the reason I
picked um I think it's fine for Global
observations yeah I just wanted uh I
wanted it to cleanly kind of get to the
end of like the 21 by 21 uh grid so yeah
I designed the original like 5331 or
whatever by uh it was for 11 by 11 mhm
so you have the leeky
okay and
then see what else there's to look at
here what other stuff could be
screwy you have the terminals reset I
think because you don't have weird
length weird length stuff
um other common screwups
technically could be hyper parameters at
this point
technically uh I don't know I think
rewards need to be visited first
off getting a reward
for do you get a negative reward for
dying you don't no I can add it though
let me see it's just in the settings
right
yeah play playing the game playing the
game is a lot different than what what's
being
rewarded uh kill reward isn't used right
now because that was ideally um when I
scale up to have more than when you win
it's fine same thing yeah well when when
I have more than two drones it becomes a
little bit more challenging to determine
like who killed who so I just haven't
done that yet
especially in this game it's not as easy
as oh who you know what bullet took
their health down this year like there
is no Health it's binary so I don't know
that'll be a little tricky because the
original game can be it's mostly good
but it can be a little weird like you
can it doesn't track kills like
perfectly but I don't really think you
can in a game like this you can kind of
approximate that was work
here um what do you mean
exactly does it just drop your actions
for three other frames or it repeat your
action oh repeats
actions and when I was playing it was I
playing it with frame skip you were yeah
good
yeah it doesn't feel amazing but it's
still very playable forame skip
4 but the thing that I'm wondering here
let me see can you only see the enemy in
the
comp
yes yeah I mean it's an approximate
position but it should be good enough
that if the policy is somewhat smart it
should be able to at least aim picking
it up
yeah I don't know if it is I think you
didn't
do did you do anything redundant
here well actually your policies are
kind of
silly how so
um it's like
small maybe maybe we maybe we should be
testing this in a simple environment
like nothing on the on the map
How would how would episodes end though
I guess you just have a time limit
episodes would end with one of them
getting pushed out to the edge no but
like oh didn't you say there's no walls
though well nothing in the middle of the
map nothing the two yeah yeah I have a I
have a map for that it's just walls and
that's it that's you then you could test
stuff like like give them a reward for
you know raming each other or something
very simple so that you can see if it's
actually working
you don't want to use the
encoder I'm just trying to make it a
little
shallower there there's a there's a lot
of
complexity I forgot to
make you shouldn't have to make oh did
you change anything with the c I think I
did H
rewards yeah you did cuz this would be
like really F if you didn't change
anything do you have some like library
for like safe arrays or
something uh it's the arrays the whole
array um the code is code
from I forget where it's on GitHub
somewhere I basically just like into a
single file thing um well to header file
Library um yeah if you go like in SRC
include like uh
the it the license at the top like has a
link to the original um GitHub but yeah
I copied
and we should actually be able to get a
network of this size to be running
decently as well by the way it's just
the the receptive fields too big because
neurals like a million
parameters H so it's just the com is
like too big the com's too slow
yeah and unfortunately torch. compile
doesn't like this
policy yeah no torch. compile is kind of
Hit or Miss I only use it for
Nur it's nice when it works
but yeah yeah nice when it
works so is 33% M time what is that tell
you just that like my inv is I don't
know something a little bit of a b
here which it shouldn't be at 800,000 by
the way it should not even be that
should not be remotely a factor
something I'm screwing you're probably
dropping a lot of that first
somewhere yeah I profiled it a bunch
like just the straight seat and it it's
most of the runtime is is all like box
2D stepping basically F
calculations um so yeah like my code is
like maybe like 5% of the the entire
thing when I'm just running like I'm
basically just stepping in a loop so I
tried to optimize it somewhat but yeah I
I don't know there's something maybe
like the python I'm not sure did you
profile like your function level call
Overhead because like set up and tear
down if you're not caching scen stuff
like that can often be a lot of
it um yeah so my C Benchmark code just
runs the environment gives it random
actions and yeah like resets it as
necessary and the setup and tear down I
think was like 3% all right that's good
so I could optimize it somewhat but it's
no we don't we don't care about 3% we
want
30% or 50% or 10x even
better yeah like 80 85% is box 2D
step well we can always fiddle with the
physics the physics resolution to see if
it needs to be as fine as it
is pretty sure I dropped it and it was
just kind of as low as they recommend
let me
see well they don't know what the hell
you're programming yeah right yeah just
to be clear we do care about 3% just we
care about those other
bigger yeah that's why I wasn't going to
spend a lot of time like optimizing my
setup and te I might be changing the
somewhat work first
even yeah exactly now you optimizing
code you're just refactor change code
that doesn't work yeah
I have optimized some stuff a little bit
but it's stuff I was like very certain
that I'm going to keep using no matter
second so increasing the net size a
bunch doesn't seem to
help not a capacity issue
rewards are looking weird now
too no cuz I added a I added a death
reward oh okay well that makes sense why
they've lost other actually look at this
they are learning to survive better here
you
see I think that they're starting to not
shoot each other
though oh right they might realize just
sitting there is the best but they
should be getting we're just sitting
learn I mean that's pretty effective
let's say
reward if you think about it they should
like go up massively they really should
be able to just survive
indefinitely they they ought to be able
to to do that because otherwise there's
you you can't do anything in the
game you see it's like
completely decided to be a pacifist
here
well the reward still sucks too I don't
no we should look at the rewards I'm G
to say it
again well yeah y they might need some
some
shots for is all down to
zero so you guys just ran a new one just
looking at the steps same oh so I I also
changed the net size which I highly
doubt it's a factor here so we can undo
that go back to faster
testing
um let me think what stuff I can come up
with here to make this work for you
today
me things
about normal sources of
[Music]
error I really don't like the gamma on
this
environment I mean have you seen what
happens if you
just I kind of want to just fiddle with
some stuff and see if it's still plays
decently do it yeah go for
it mess it
up so can I set this is frame
rate yeah that affects like physics and
stuff um that'll make physics wacky I
mean you can if you just want to
see you should actually I'm curious go
and play like the demo and see what
that's like that'll make the physics I'm
not sure if it makes it I forget okay I
can't remember if that makes the physics
like six times faster or
timing well the frame rate is used to
step physics as well because like the
physics are stepped like
uh
where or what did you oh you have to run
make debug demo if you want to do the C
thing yeah it's uh H in the middle
yeah
debug yeah this is just get pulling the
stuff get cloning the stuff um I guess
you're not up to the latest commit
because I added I I actually uncommented
that so it's always visible bet so you
can just see what the status is because
if your internet slow it just seems like
it's h yeah I hope we're not stuck in
the download
we might I think we
are but this should be a onetime thing
now that they fix the other C make stuff
so cuz yeah see you're using gnu 11 now
and that'll work you can probably use
like gcc1 and it should work
fine yeah here we
go that looks
good big
rip
um is wait did I see an assert there
somewhere yeah there was an
assert
there
offset it's m.h line 13
132 we're getting things oh also when
you make this thing does it have the
address sanitizer on for the python
builds no not when you're doing like a
normal make because you would know
because if you try to run from the
python it' freak out because it's uh
dynamically
linked yeah exactly
so yeah I have got it working like um
debugging like the uh yeah building the
python module in debug mode so can run
it with the address sanitizer I can
train with it but yeah that's not the
default good cuz that's
slower yeah way
slower so okay just do a get diff for me
because I'm this I'm kind of surprised
well I mean all I did look all I did
was was this right I know that shouldn't
cause the assertion to fail so that's
some it be the physics throwing up
somehow like one of my observation
asserts is triggering oh
no still happens now okay what yeah do a
get
132 okay yeah I'm mostly interested in
to
see that's it what oh the map index but
really is it hard Cod
20 maybe again I did this really quick
yesterday so I might I guess I screwed
something up let me take a look where
the wasn't line 31 no it was not is
there a map size here
[Music]
somewhere well I have a Max map type but
it's 21 by 21 so it should be
fine assert I is oh I probably just need
to make that less than or equal to
um try changing line wait I S didn't see
we
did let me see if I'll try locally see
if this fixes
it I have it on the other map at
Works Cool leave it leave the other
map I think this might be one line fix
if I if I'm thinking if I'm right
yeah oh wait I'm not in the same map let
me change
lovely map
upid yeah my uh assertions are a little
too overzealous I guess why still not
work oh is it
random if you commented out yeah it's
random
or wait what's what are you talking
about what's
can they hit themselves in this game do
they lose points they can they lose
points if they shoot themselves into a
wall
ah you Chang it to five
FPS yeah
the physics still work
dude they do but I'm just saying the
frame rate affects um like how physics
work basically so you don't just change
the frame rate of the game you change
like the tick rate of the physics looks
fine to me yeah I I do know that they
they tell you not to use variable frame
rates for box 2D but I think if you're
using a constant frame rate
it's usually okay so I want the box to
be Discord and ask because they've never
as far as well yeah it's from their
reactions they've never had anyone
trying to run box 2D like millions of
frames per second basically but they
said yeah the flare guys literally
rewrote it in
Jack oh yeah right which I I actually
went and looked through the project the
code for that project and it's like this
is incredibly impr impressive but you
guys are giving yourself so much more
suffering than you need
to like holy hell you guys just love
suffering I
guess I we're going to help him out they
come in here that's a very very good
idea I've definitely been down the the
Jack's path before it's not
fun never I'm blissfully unaware of the
Jack
struggles basically researchers decided
that they would rather write code in a
python like DSL or array programming
language than write anything other than
Python and that went about as well as
you'd expect yeah sounds like a great
idea cuz C is I need to get your
uh yeah yeah apparently C is just
terrible or something what do you need
to get of mine uh what was the index map
it was it two for the snipers map yeah
the one you're using
yeah let's see if we get this to work
make
works there might just there might be a
bug on my end because I think I'm
looking into that like assert that got
triggered and I think it's
legit so I'm looking into that well I'm
hoping it's just with the
demo no I I I think it's in how oper uh
observations are
calculated so it seems like these
sir um might be
like I might be uh stepping over one too
many uh going into like
the one too many cells on my second a
when I'm Computing the observation for
the second agent but I'm not
sure shoot
this is this is the
same we're looking
I think it's hyper parameters let me
think here so
I wonder if we can
now change some
like can I do this
now you
know you you you
can well the reason you realize why I
think I should be able
to why do you think he I took it down to
five OBS per second so 0.95 should be
about a 4 second 4 second
Horizon right which still isn't that
which still isn't that much I'm long
enough for a bullet to hit the
enemy let's see
no not
second oh steps per
second wait you can see it it says
180k
okay
[Music]
ceasefire yeah that's that's I was
curious earlier about if they could
shoot themselves like I wonder if
there's some sort of it is probably
exactly
that exactly
what that they don't want to shoot
themselves so they stop
firing oh yeah that that might be
because they aren't directly punished
for shooting themselves but if they you
know kill themselves then they cease
getting rewards so it's kind of a
punishment Band-Aid Pat would be to add
a very small reward for
firing there have been some policies
well actually that was pre actions fix I
don't know if there's any I don't think
that there have been any Poli at all no
no no good policies but there were some
previous policies that would fire at
every step and I know that because they
would pick up a weapon like the sniper
or the imploder and they would charge
like
good I'm seeing like pretty consistently
drone zero reboard above Throne
same I was hoping that would
work um but I mean I guess it's possible
can we add like a shots fired
reward yeah it should be pretty
where do this get changed is a source
game
correct I mean the other thing that may
could be happening is if the rewards are
getting mixed up between the agents
right like it's discouraging shooting
yeah that could be the case but as far
as I can tell it's not
happening you're zeroing the rewards
between time steps and everything
right uh yeah the common one is
forgetting to Zer your
buffers I've never made that mistake
ever that makes me want to check my code
now I think I do it man yeah that's a
common this whole process will just
continue to get easier and
easier yeah I do it in Step
M good and the way I do frame skipping
this is correct right so I reset rewards
at the beginning of the step and then I
do the frame SK yeah yeah and I just
accumulate yeah
Christmas what kind of
chair random outlet mall chair or random
like Furniture Outlet chair it's nice
though it's this
thing oh look
here what thing
where the thing I'm sitting in
that
thing what was wrong with the old chair
oh I still have it here it's an office
to this is like a nice
recliner so actually this is a this will
be a nice test cuz this will actually
this will tell us quite a
bit so now we have a reward curve that
goes
up right oh because it's actually it's
just being rewarded for firing so it's
actually it is learning stuff something
else is
screwy I'm curious if this will be good
enough to do it
I I think that what is being rewarded is
not is not aligned with playing the
game how would you
know because playing the game is more
more than
just not dying and firing although they
should be not dying in the very
least well remember a totally different
time scale
is there
a I think oh sorry go ahead distance
travel should should go up uh with this
if they're shooting because they're
they're not going to be like moving
absolute distance from where they start
but they're going to be wiggling back
and forth constantly because because of
firing so distance traveled should go up
I think uh I I think they might crash
more too into walls due to lack of
ability to to to keep themselves from
doing it but we'll see let's see if the
reward continues to go
up because we actually I have a curve
that goes up I've produced a curve that
goes up where previously there were no
curves going up right that's that is
actually a big
deal this means that your general
training setup seems to at least be
working that it can solve a a very basic
task now the question that I have is
whether this is actually going to be
enough to get it to do um to do better
can it fire every
step he's AFK oh
okay we'll chill for a
funny did he change it did he change his
is that actually a
okay so this is kind of funny it
takes like it it literally can fire
every step and it takes it 100 no it
takes it 28 million steps just to learn
to like fire every
step yeah I'm not sure your gamma
calculations are are correct that is the
effective Horizon is like well the
effective Horizon of that particular
thing that would be like gamma is equal
to 0.5 or
whatever
oh it's definely
something it's I mean it should
be question is how how much reward can
they get there should be a maximum
amount that they can get from just
firing
you would also if this policy is at all
decent I will uh I will claim victory
for the
evening
yeah uh I don't I don't declare Victory
till I till I see the
eval well this is at least progress
regardless yeah at least we know it's
doing something
I don't know this might be a somewhat
difficult environment to train on I
didn't think it'd be this difficult but
it's I would mostly just bet on ourl
being
screwy like I said this is the plan for
2025 so like if you think about the
amount of pain that this has that you
have like getting this thing to work
here even with me here right the goal
for the end of 2025 is to reduce that by
at least an order of
magnitude yeah that'd be
great what's the what's the
strategy for for that uh we're going to
just run tens of trillions of steps of
experiments and ablations and like
method studies and see what actual
components of RL matter which are
ridiculously sensitive which we can
replace things like this basically the
only thing in the way from uh for me
starting that is I've got a bunch of
full contributor environments to merge
in that need attention and then I've got
uh some lab
collaborations as well as um a couple of
clients to Circle back
with as
well well I gotta head out but uh thank
you very much for all your help I will
uh I will put a summary once we look at
this
policy cool um I should have a bit of
time to like you know like hop on a
stream whatever tomorrow but uh yeah
I'll let you know
I think that will be pretty well set by
tomorrow as well basically after this
I'm going to go read for a bit and then
go to sleep and that's about
it well you all have a good night all
right see youer have a good
night Dam damn Joseph so no no code code
review for your contributors I see how
it is well I'm literally right now this
is a this is me working on a contributor
project right here
I'm talking Enduro I know I yes I know
you're I have not forgotten about Enduro
and blastar for that matter yeah LOL
blastar that was
hard you're getting a full code riew on
both so I've been doing you a favor by
not doing your code review while I'm a
sick and grumpy to like B uh post root
canal and grumpy or following bottle of
wine Christmas Eve drunken grump
all
right so so far there's been a total of
like a day or two maybe where I could
have even potentially done it and I
haven't even been on my aame
yet what drunk Joseph is
aame H well to be fair my I very rarely
do that my my rational there was I just
had a 2hour nightmare root canal so I
can either have some wine and be
tolerable with my family on Christmas
Eve
or I can have no wine and basically be
the Grinch so yeah I'm I'm known I'm
known to be grumpy at family gatherings
too I shouldn't be but uh I had two be
last perfectly tolerable a bottle I
haven't drank alcohol in I don't know
eight months 10 months I don't drink
much at
all I think this is the guy that yet
seeing hired to like work on his ding
board
thing ding board this is
[ __ ] oh what's what's sting
board this guy is funny as hell he like
this guy blew up on Twitter like by just
yapping a whole bunch and then he made
like a an online the original thing he
did is he made like an online image
editor and he was like I'm going to beat
photosho by making an image editor that
doesn't suck
online ah easy you'll just you know make
a better Photoshop to be fair if you've
ever used the online version of
Photoshop it's not that hard that app is
dog
[ __ ] the desktop version's
fine do we do we have a do we have an
adobe enjoyer in the in the chat here
I've used I've used Photoshop
up rewards Plateau it looks like well
first of all this isn't a reward this
has got to be like return or something
because
a reward of seven doesn't make
sense yo did y'all figure
out uh Spencer we're literally in the
Discord right
now yeah can you not hear him on the you
can hear him on the stream right be on
stream
uh he should be able to hear I didn't
hear myself necessarily but that's
because I muted the stream if if I've
been talking on like one side of a
conversation and nobody's told me on the
Stream the whole time that's on yall you
were you were you were audible when I
because I have I have it so it should be
piping desktop
audio I have it what's up definitely he
hey how's it going
Spencer chilling no I mean I just hopped
in a second ago I didn't I wasn't really
watching the whole
time well we have I added a reward for
firing
bullets okay
this reward does go
up excellent also the length of the game
has gone up such that now these
are these games are over a minute I
believe so that's something I also I did
a bunch of other stuff I like I made it
so that there's no frame Skip and the
physics only uh and there's only five
observations per
second um for some reason that makes the
M stupid slow but
I mean look at I like this reward curve
looks decent to me it does except I mean
it looks much better than when I tuned
in a few hours ago where it did
literally nothing I mean it seems like
it is actually like learning and
optimizing stuff now at the very
least uh let's look at the length curve
where is that
that sucks no it doesn't suck remember
the other curves were before I reduced
it from like 60 FPS for frame
skip can we so this is a totally
different scale can we change the scale
of the graph to get rid of the or just m
get rid of those other runs on
there entropy is not crashing it's 6
point whatevers should be fine
value loss goes up a bit but then you
know it's very accurate here TR scale is
not
exploding this is a variance it looks
like it's doing things no the scale of
explained variance is fine as well clip
Frack is very
low reward
why is distance
traveled ABS this is ABS distance
traveled I don't know they might just be
standing in place and shooting at each
other they definitely they definitely
are just in
place
um maybe that's all they want to do you
know yeah they haven't learned how to
Juke yet go scroll up you went past
length
uh up oh right there distance traveled
goes up because the episode length goes
up so I think needs to modify somebody
these metrics I think reward is actually
episodic
return oh look it's it actually but look
it's it's shooting more but it's hitting
itself less you see
this yes
well those are different drones right Dr
but still look it's going
down so it's firing like a madman but
it's actually hitting itself
less is it a learning to shoot and Dodge
its own shots that's the big question I
think is it aiming it is not ah I could
tell you right now okay let's watch evil
then let's let it do 100 mli
did SPS tank just due to the end being
complicated SPS apparently tanked with
whatever I changed with the
physics ah so somebody will have to look
into that this is an
unacceptable uh physics
speed is this because of box 2D or did
he do custom
physics
uh well I can get up to up to 450k on a
puffer box yesterday so with box 2D yes
with box
I I don't understand what the
uh what is this guy this guy is just
like a troll he like he started off
building all this like all these
actually kind of cool projects uh and he
like he then he just started doing like
he just started gaming the X algorithm
and his account just really blew up and
then he uh he tried to sell his like
image editor to Elon and Elon didn't buy
it but he offered him a job at X so now
he works at
X and he like really tests the limits of
what he can get away with posting on X
without getting
fired I mean he'll do stuff like he'll
like he'll post like one side of an
offensive take and then he'll make
another post with the other side of the
offensive take just so he gets the
engagement from
both there there's I mean the community
notes should should take care of that
though right so
in factual like it's not like he's
posting like
misinformation he like he'll post like I
don't know he'll post I think like with
Ukraine or whatever no no no it's I'm
more with like text stuff he'll post
like you know X is like the best thing
ever and then it'll post like X is the
worst thing
ever I don't
know he also posts like he also posts a
bunch of other crazy [ __ ] it's funny
I seen the way worse things on the
internet so it's like
uh I
mean EV EV EV can I just do it in
parallel yeah probably
this is this shouldn't be occupying all
of your CPU
the Moment of
Truth dude that's
hilarious you fixed
it Red's about to die
though oh no no
nope they found an angle to shoot at so
that they don't shoot themselves
I think uh it might have changed it from
a zero sum to like a common sum game rip
because it's like they can both maybe
get more reward if they just don't kill
each other yeah yeah they should still
learn to kill each other though if it
were easy enough for them to learn to do
so right so remove the [ __ ] in the
middle so they can actually shoot each
other I mean I wonder like is there
some reason they are not moving
anymore just easier to learn like this
strategy to not run into stuff they are
actively moving Against The Recoil I
mean that's a legit policy though at the
very
least uh but here's here's my question
why are they firing in the same
direction yeah a good question because
they have the same policy dude wait a
second if they have if they both have
the same policy then
are they going to have mirrored
actions uh not
necessarily but different OB then this
can happen yeah it's it's OB
conditional I still think it's
suspicious that they happen to
be the same
exact Direction it's just they learned a
non they just learned an unconditioned
policy it's
all wonder if they ever figure out to
shoot each
other you could probably add like a
fairly simple aim reward of like when
you're facing the
enemy
yep well they get a reward for hitting
the
enemy Maybe not maybe that's too far
away maybe that's too hard or maybe it's
not weighted enough but we definitely
got something here
right yeah it's avoiding self do thing
yes now the thing is like I think that
you honestly if you got like a little
scripted one it wouldn't be that hard to
like make a scripted bot that just like
tries to run at the opponent and shoot
at them
right are they running on like some type
of visual uh like limit or is are they
have full observability they're full
observability but for the scripted boss
you just ignore that and use great game
State um
so like if you I think that if you were
to run a sweep you should run a sweep
against a scripted bot so that you can
get uh because otherwise like you end up
with the selfplay
issues here let's let's run this I'll go
a screenshot
for I mean I think when he first came up
with this end I was encouraging at least
having a bot that just like shoots at
the enemy or shoots at your
agent are they actually hit each other
kind of uh they're they're boun at the
the exact angle to hit each
other I wish there was like a health
score counter
somewhere yeah the problem is it's just
one one and done one death and it's
over is this resetting every time or
they not hitting each other they might
be hitting each other but they're
resisting uh their their little
thrusters
are against the direction that they're
being
pushed that's what those rectangles are
behind
them I don't think they're being hit if
it's one hit kill no no no no the the
kill is if they touch the red anything
touching red oh that's right you have to
push them into the wall not get hit by
the projectile you have to push the
other one into the wall could we make
the bullets push them a lot harder than
they curently are so it's more difficult
to resist being knocked
around like I don't know it's not really
proper physics well the answer is yes
and what they ought to do then is is do
what we saw them doing before where
they're firing uh on different sides
I mean it kind of seems like if if
there's a reward for hitting and there's
a reward for
shooting there is in a way
a reward just for prolonging the episode
for both
agents saying there
is there is a is a way to reward episode
prolongation
well I in that case wouldn't you like
you typically add like a negative value
to the reward so it
doesn't
hey hi everyone you on stream by the way
just letting people know who you're
here oh on
Twitter
yeah say hi
YouTube we just have what is we got like
five people watching us at the moment
speaking of which people please do star
puff it helps a lot
um yeah no to what we're doing is we are
uh we've been trying to fix this
environment that I just put this graphic
in the uh in the chat for and we got it
to do kind of something uh unfortunately
the settings that now work it's very
slow so we got to fix that but we're
going to have this like physics based
Arena shooter that Captain made I tried
to get this thing working well
oh see yeah uh so what I was say for the
what go ahead yeah go ahead I was going
to just say like if you want to stop it
the the episodes not being so long you
could add a negative reward of like
minus one every time you step so like in
the long run taking task that
wouldn't and the environments would
cause your reward to be negative
although you have to scale the negative
reward well though we can be very the
might become too scared to the
connection if they always get a negative
point1 I don't think that does anything
I thought that you'd have to do
uh yeah think about it I don't know it
depends how handle
terminals my my concern is that maybe
the like cumulative reward is much
higher just for shooting
yeah than for actually like eliminating
the
other
um it probably is it's also just easier
to learn so I mean I can lower this uh I
could definitely lower this but I think
that you're going to get the most out of
just having a scripted opponent to use
initially and then that'll let you tune
this thing and then you'll probably be
able to
go probably be able to go from there
decently well
um I also think we should probably just
add like a box blur onto this or
something at some point add some sort of
a Shader actually you can probably copy
a lot of what I did with the MOBA Shader
to be
fair like I might be able to help with
that I you
know don't have a lot of RA experience
but I do have experience with uh 2D
graphics and well I did this for the
mobile find it oh yeah make it make it
look make it look nice space So Co
appreciate that so like here this is the
Moa and you see I added like this Shader
on the edge of this like the edge of the
tiles it changes color like slowly like
it breathes over time it's not like this
transitions this is just a Shader and
it's it's open source as part of the uh
the
Moa
nice f makes me want to play league so
I'm not allowed to even play L MOBA too
much leag it's okay I have h i I
literally it's impossible because I have
I don't have a Windows install we're
safe for now he's safe he's safe W wood
league is safe what a what a chat dude I
don't even they need to make a new rank
for me okay like iron is too
hard
yeah just
don't it's not worth
it let's see what this has done in the
meantime I love their rewards are like
identical by the
way
H Dr Drone zero and drone drone one have
basically
but this is still going
see I could maybe also help with past oh
looks like you got
I mean with the the obstacles for that
map in the screenshot there I think you
could just move in the
direction of the opponent and then like
look a few tiles ahead I don't think you
would need anything too complicated to
probably do something simple so I did
something really kind of cool with the
Moa um
cuz like the Moa is a good example of an
M that you actually have to get a little
bit clever on if you want it to be
fast cuz like if you look at a
MOA you see all these puffers
here each of these is pathing right in
real time and then all these guys
they're they will follow me if I like
smack
them ago right they'll Agro me and
they'll pass and uh some of these
obstacles are thinner than they look but
like they will path around here
right like they follow me and stuff and
uh they do this their pathing is 0 of
one um where's your where's your Tower
your Tower's not going to shoot
them uh I don't know if Towers shoot
neutrals I don't think they do because
neutrals don't attack Towers so but yeah
so this
is It's funny is it like a is it table
based uh yeah so the way it works is we
cut the grid up into 128 by 28 cells and
we pre-compute all paths from like all
cells to all cells we literally
pre-compute or cach at least 250
megabytes of pathing data but then it's
literally just an array look up to
compute I thought that was kind of cool
there's even there's a little demo of it
as well let see there's like a real time
demo
it is there a way to search your own
posts
maybe I think it's designed
for oh here it
no oh yeah yeah here it is this gift is
that
cool so it computes vectors from every
position you see so this is real time
just me dragging it
around I
computes is it's all just
C it's
wild I definitely make sense if you're
just if you're going for as as much
speed as possible and trading some
memory for that
8.5 reward did that go
up yeah it has been going up oh wait
hold on did just figure something
out I don't know we'd have to wait and
see have to wait and see that looks like
a
spike maybe not I don't know that's I
think it looks the
same I see this little Spike at the end
and I'm excited you know come on Joseph
that's really a
stretch I don't know it's been it's been
it's been flat and noisy for the entire
run is
dead
rip well it did learn this bit
here it learned how to how to shoot yes
and not crash well it it got better over
time as well like that's not a perfectly
flat it's like a shallow
ler it's
like it it doesn't have access to any
other rewards I don't think
so it did learn to like not shoot itself
so
much okay I mean that's at least
possible to start with though um
scripted by I think I let Captain do uh
work on this for a couple days before I
look Stu so it's 7:26 so I'm going to
bed soon but um I go to bed really early
these days but uh for
tomorrow do you want me to finally uh
review full review Enduro bed or what
what do you want to do here sure that's
fine okay so I can full review Enduro
whenever I see you on I suppose um basic
basically the stuff I have to do before
we really get onto the new